good morning john it's monday and
pizzamas is going by very quickly so
quickly that it is reminding me of a
video that i've wanted to do for a very
long time because i'm fascinated by what
happens when you ask seemingly simple
questions like for example what's the
fastest thing sounds like that would be
really objective and that you could just
answer it and be done with it like the
answer is light light is the fastest
thing but is light a thing it's not
matter it doesn't have mass i can't like
grab it also in some cases particles can
go faster than light as long as the
light isn't traveling through a vacuum
so yeah the interesting thing to me is
that i think a bunch of different people
could have this same title for a video
and make very different videos but
here's the video that i would make here
are the top four six i don't know things
that are the fastest let's start out
with the fastest a person has ever gone
now for a long time that was just
running and then it was horses and
actually i have bad news it was neither
of those things for a long time the
fastest person was someone who did not
survive because they were falling off of
something very high up the terminal
velocity of a human body in our
atmosphere is 120 miles per hour you can
easily reach that if you fall off just
you know a number of different
waterfalls and the 120 miles per hour
that somebody probably experienced while
falling off of a waterfall or a cliff
somewhere was not exceeded until the
1900s specifically probably in the 1910s
or 1920s we're not entirely sure because
cars were very new and people were
driving them very fast and we didn't
have great ways to measure how fast they
were going anyway people were definitely
going over 120 miles per hour by the
1920s and then over the next few decades
we very rapidly increased our top speed
until the 60s when we had gone from 120
miles per hour to over 24 000. and that
record set in the 1960s by three people
at the same time has not yet been beaten
and we are not on the way to beating it
the three people in question were tom
stafford john young and eugene cernan
and they were on the way home from the
moon they did not land on because this
was apollo 10. it went faster on the way
back to earth than any other apollo
mission i don't think because they were
like in a hurry to get home i'm guessing
it was just because of like orbital
mechanics reasons but yeah that's the
fastest a person has ever gone and we're
not looking to exceed it until probably
we head to mars but we have made lots of
things that have gone way faster than
apollo 10. but here's the thing that's
pretty easy to understand as an orbit
gets lower it gets faster so mercury
orbits the sun faster than venus which
orbits faster than earth which orbits
faster than mars and so if you want to
get a probe really close to the sun to
do science on the sun it's going to be
going very fast during the part of its
orbit when it's close to the sun and
that brings us to the parker solar probe
which this year broke its own record for
the fastest a man-made object has ever
gone with around 330 000 miles per hour
now very strangely this might not be the
fastest a man-made object has ever gone
if you remember my 2017 wheezy waiter
paternity leave video you'll know about
this but it might be that the fastest
man-made object ever was the manhole
cover that capped an underground nuclear
test that went slightly awry the shock
of the explosion was vented improperly
and so it all went to this one manhole
cover which was then of course blasted
off there was a high-speed camera
running and the manhole cover appears in
one frame of the high-speed film that
allowed scientists to calculate that at
minimum it was going 125 000 miles per
hour and there wasn't enough data to put
a maximum on that so it could have been
going significantly faster than that
that manhole cover may have been blasted
into space where it would still be or it
may have vaporized as it slammed through
the atmosphere either way it did not
fall back to earth and that brings us to
the final question all right so those
are the fastest things that we've made
what's just the fastest thing hank
what's the fastest thing and if we're
not counting a light in a vacuum because
of course that is the fastest thing the
fastest stuff that has mass well that
would be like the superheated jets of
plasma that come off of active galactic
nucleuses so supermassive black holes at
the center of galaxies called blazars
blazars shoot big globs of this plasma
out some of them like as big as the
planet jupiter going over 99 the speed
of light why does this happen i have no
idea and then here at the end a quick
note speed is a function of distance and
time and time it turns out is relative
and so speed itself kind of doesn't
exist but pizzamas does and it's going
fast and you can go to petesmith.com
right now to see all of the amazing
products that we have available now that
will never be available after the end of
this week john i'll see you tomorrow the
fastest thing in the world